my most successful tweet ever by a
fairly wide margin
some reporter tweeted it Elon Musk uh
because he was complaining about
Wikipedia or something you should buy
Wikipedia and I just wrote not for sale
nice and you know 90 zillion retweets
and people liked it and it was all very
good
um but I'm like you know what it's cute
line right and it's a good like mic drop
and all that and I I was pleased with
myself like it's not really discourse
right it's not really sort of the what I
like to do but it's what social media
really rewards which is kind of uh lets
you and him have a fight right and
that's more interesting I mean it's
funny because at the time I was I was
texting with Elon who was very pleasant
to me all of that and it's funny he
might have been a little bit shitty the
reporter might have been a little bit
shitty but you fed into the shitty
snarky funny response not for sale and
like where do you like what so that's a
funny little exchange and you could
probably after that laugh it off and
yeah fun well like that kind of
mechanism that rewards the snark yeah
you can go into viciousness yeah yeah
well and we certainly see it
um online you know I like a a series of
tweets you know sort of a a a tweet
thread of 15 tweets that assesses the
quality the evidence for masks pros and
cons and and sort of where this that's
not going to go viral you know
um but you know a Smackdown for
a famous politician who is famously in
favor of mask who also went to a dinner
and didn't wear a mask that's going to
go viral and you know that that's partly
human nature
um you know people love to call out
hypocrisy and all that but it's partly
what these systems elevate